taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
taste buds hey sweeties and sweetie pies
it's uh taste buds
yeah the show where me and this guy
debate food
yeah i mean if you if you've been
watching if you're new to taste buds
we're the buds where the butts you see
that the name is very witty you see
we went through dozens of choices and we
thought taste but we debate foods all
the time when we hang out
and with fervor with them and vigor we
debate
am i right yes we're passionate about it
we don't mind we will have up
what an ideal day for us would be is if
we have an exchange of dialogue
will we just really dig in and and go
over the minutia of something
yes over and over it's how that it's how
we are wired
yes and it happens all the time and a
lot of times it happens
with food options and so here we debate
food we put the twitter poll out at the
top
of the episode we pick a side um
it is based though and what we feel
passionate about so we're not just
arguing for arguing sake here right
that's a big caveat that i don't know if
you ever mentioned it's got to be
something
that we disagree on organically and
not that you hate the other item but
hands down you will die on the hill of
the item you're defending versus the
other item yes
100 100 and sometimes you do hate the
other item
yeah uh sometimes you don't but uh these
are real food debates we've had
in private and now we're bringing them
public uh
that's right at the end of the episode
uh these are like
fun little half hour episodes we uh have
a segment called humble pie where we go
to the polls
and we use the polls as the be-all
end-all answer to
uh to the debate that we're having and
uh you know the person who loses
it's a little bit humble by right right
even though they're still right
we like puns we like food puns we were
leaning and hard to the food taste buds
pumpkin pie apple pie i'm sure we'll
come up with more yeah
something i mean you know we're gonna
start getting yeah
that was one of them too yeah yes but
taste buds was perfect
facebook just i mean yeah we should if
you have them in your phone one day is
it like a little thing we should read
all the things you maybe we're going to
call it and then uh
yeah and then wait no my phone's
charging all right another time we'll do
another one yeah
um so today's throwdown yes
this is a big one this is what is the
best
traditional pod pie
traditional apple not apple crumb none
of the crumb stuff just regular straight
up apple pie
versus regular straight up peach pie
pie uh i predict right out of the gate
that this is the first episode of taste
buds where i will walk away the victor
because sal has foolishly
chosen peach peach
pie i stand by it ever since i'm little
i have nothing against apple i really
got to be in the mood for apple i think
it's overplayed i think don't listen we
didn't start the poll yet okay don't
waste your sorry
i was going in hard on the app don't
waste your jesus she's already
here you go you got better pie
traditional apple traditional peach and
that's a tweed right there
it's out it's out all right now go ahead
with let the
obnoxiousness you were just spewing you
know a few things in my life
you're just about to say i'm sick of
apple pie were you just about to yeah i
was gonna
really yeah but then i decided to
explain to you what i mean okay
apple pie i don't hate it but i have to
be in the mood for it and it is
delicious when made right
especially with a scoop ice cream hot
but again we're not adding the bells and
whistles
so you're talking about a slice of
traditional apple pie on its own
and a slice of peach pie on its own
there are a few things in my life that i
can name that i've had that i used to
love and then i ate them so much i got
sick of them
and i'm not saying that had one apple
pie i didn't eat apple pie until i got
sick of it but apple pie is around so
much that i am sick of it
it's just like don't get me wrong if
there's no other pie and you're like do
you want a nice hot slice of apple pie
i'll be like i have it you know what i i
find a lot with apple pie
i'll take a bite i'll take two bites if
it's not crumb or it doesn't have any
other bells and whistles
i tap out after a couple of bites it's a
little too much
of that apple saucy
i extend it really to the apple the
apple is the culprit i'm
i was never a big apple fan my whole
life i think the apples are
a little too pungent a little too sweet
and tart and i take a bite of an apple
and i chew and i go no i get it i get it
i get it apple's close to a pair and a
pair can take a [ __ ] and jump off a
bridge
a pair is terrible but anyway um you
don't like pears
a pear i think is is it's the most
overrated fruit ever
in existence no that's the cantaloupe is
the most overrated
no way cantaloupe is great okay another
episode okay mark it down
i i pay over as a candle it's just a
free versafine
i'll smash it for fun i i won't even put
it in my mouth
okay i've never seen someone purchase a
pet
that's already been in the market with
me it's a whole other episode
show me don't listen all right this is
exactly what we do
and we just write it down so the thing
about the apple pie
is like it's always the go-to pie as
well like
my i think conversely one of the best
fruits ever made the swan
i mean the fruit of all fruits is a
peach
when you have the right peach a ripe
beautiful peach is better than a perfect
apple it really is
a peach is succulent juicy bursting with
flavor
citrus notes it just livens just taste
buds your senses
it is invigorating i love it i love
peach and
my iced tea i love peach peach is
a as as as versatile as an apple is i
think a peach is
nearly as versatile with none of the
credit
uh granted my favorite dish is more of
like a cobbler or whatever
but i will tell you peaches aren't
always in season it's a treat to get a
peach pie
uh everything a peach represents just a
juicy beautiful peach
i feel like it's a summery thing now i
know apple pie
is america rah-rah like you i know the
speech you're going to give no you don't
it's
it's it's it's it's because it's it's
like a hug from your mother just like
the cinnamon raisin bag
that's not what i was going to say what
i was going to say is a peach
in its pure form is everything you
described it as
and then somebody takes it and cuts it
up and
ruins it by putting it into a hot
mess of a thing it tastes eating up the
apple
apple's a different story i'll take a
peach over an
apple off the tree any day of the week
you cook those things you cook those
things you're in different territory
now you want to talk about uh two
like everything you described that's
good about the peach
is lost in peach pie you get none of
that flavor in peach pie
peach pie just tastes sugary
it just tastes sweet none of the layered
notes of an actual piece where are you
buying your peach pies
where you buying your apple pie that
you're saying there's too much soupiness
in it or whatever the hell soupiness i
said the apple sauciness
that's around all the apples when you
cut it all that stuff that's like it's
almost like the uh
like like in the stuff like every pie
like you you need the stuff to bond it
like
yeah yeah every pie has that stuff yeah
but it's too appley for me
but every pie has that
every i'm saying you gotta but not the
ones that's in the at like the apple on
apple it's just it's just too much it
looks like it looks like a lot of nice
apples
seal that gunk in the middle that brown
gunk look at peach pie peach pie looks
like it's not even like a real food by
the time it comes out look out look at
the color of it
a peach pie a beautiful vibrant peach
pie with look at the color of it it
looks unnatural
unnatural it looks orange orange is a
primary color what do you tell me it's
roiji biv
it's the owen roy that looks unnatural
dude and that doesn't taste like peaches
when you eat it and you know it it
doesn't taste like peaches
now this is a classic derosa move he
takes and now he's shifting the argument
to
he's he's making you think that peach
pie doesn't taste like peaches
does he okay but i mean for the this
these purposes a peach pie i'm talking
about
the tasting of a peach pie so you're
going to take away the fact that my
peach probably tastes like peaches
here's how much it doesn't taste like
peaches
i love canned peaches i love peach
peaches
i love uh fruit cocktail with the
peaches in it okay
peach pie and peach cobbler are the only
two forms of peach
i don't i love peach iced tea it's my
favorite flavor
peach pineapple i mean listen to what
he's saying peach pie chooses a peach
off the tree over an apple
and peach iced tea is his favorite oh
your favorite iced tea is not apple
peach pie and peach cobbler are the only
two flavors of peach i don't like
because they don't taste like peach i
lose the peas
and peaches are loaded with sugar my
friend
that is not the natural peach i think
we're like a pizza
right you get yourself we're both saying
here
pick your pick the bakery or the chef or
whatever that's making
the best of the best i'm talking about
the best not like
you had some peach pie that didn't taste
like peach i'm talking about
let's talk about the both pies the way
that they should be presented look at
that
jelly mess it's disgusting looking look
at that
no it's it's disgusting looking it is
that looks like
gorgeous and and there's little notes of
red on the skin that they left in there
and you get these deep notes of red with
these bright orange slices
you want colors go look at a [ __ ]
pollock painting i'm talking about
flavor here
i want to taste the pie i want it to
taste good that looks nuts to me
that looks absolutely nice to me we're
not even getting into a scoop of ice
cream and a
dollop of whipped cream but if you put
you don't want to go down that road
an apple pie it's on it's on menus and
restaurants
it's all a mode and you can add it to
any part don't open that door for
yourself
a dollop of whipped cream is way better
on a peach pie than an apple pie i said
it and i'll
stand by it who gives a [ __ ] whipped
cream can take a swim i don't care
i i'm all right but
then all right well fine but whipped
cream for me stops at cool whip
if it ain't cool whip i don't i could
care less you had the nerve
in the last episode to say that
everything bagel seasoning was for trash
people
and you're telling me your whipped cream
stops at cool whip if it ain't cool whip
you don't want anything
yeah i didn't say miracle whip that
would be trash cool whip i thought i'm
talking about fresh made whipped cream
and you brought up cool whips
whipped cream again nothing that's cool
with i have cool up downstairs and i
have ready whip and i love whipped cream
but if i'm not having it nothing has
ever taken up more needless space on a
plate this is what's getting ready
this is what you do what go ahead you
did this too
you applied you applied the argument to
the
you denied me my argument for the oreo
and then you took that same thing and
you applied it
to the cinnamon raisin bagel you pick
sides you play the sides
and now now you're talking about you
play the sides
with what how am i playing the side
because you just said what did you just
say
i said ready w miracle whip
is cool whip or cool whip you say you
don't want to hit nothing when it comes
to cool
but then you had the you had the i said
i said nothing takes up more useless
space on a plate than ready with
my point to you is you said it's the
buck stops at cool whip with you yeah
whipped cream and i said to you you had
the yes you had the gumption yes
and you had the you had the sack yes to
tell me
that everything bagel uh seasoning yes
in a
in a jar yes is for trash people yes
and then you told me the buck stops at
cool whip with you yeah
and and you're not playing sides no dude
every time angle seasons
like you got cool whip and like you were
like i mean it's like
it's entry level stuff and god bless you
too
you're telling me you're telling me
everything you know everything
bagel mix in a jar by trader joe's is a
good
artistic gourmet topping that it was
only really
put into it was only really put into the
market in the last couple of years
it sells at a premium that is an item
that is much more artisanal
than a bucket of cream the bucket of
cool it's got your precious peaches on
there damn right it does
i told you i told you let me tell you
this let me tell you this this is how
much i stand by what i see people
cool whips like kool-aid i like it but
it's also on the
on the bottom of the rung of ladder
whereas an artisanal thing
like an everything baby okay i'm so
confused by the clash of you having both
in your kitchen downstairs because i
know that you have it depends on my mood
i feel like i just went into a trailer
in a trailer park and saw a rembrandt on
the wall
i don't know what direction this guy's
coming that's what i'm saying about you
you you have some nerve because you you
can't call everything bagel seasoning
for trash people and then say cool whip
is for the hierarchy
for the you can't say it's for the the
iphone the capulets of the montagues it
doesn't work like that
to be a rare commodity what do you want
from me it looks we're getting off
you open gatsby you open gatsby's
refrigerator
you think you see an everything bagel
seasoning first or a bucket of cream a
bucket of cool
you're crazy cool whip crazy now i know
you're not playing with a full deck
cool whip before listen to me okay cool
whip comes up
witness search cool it comes out with
tang and pop rocks
well that's a cool it comes up on cool
up comes up next to
uh the the drink of our fine astronauts
the brave men in outer space i'm proud
to see it there
and next to pop rocks which i also
consider whoa
wait hold on a minute because we do say
this is educational sometimes
the reason those came up together is the
same guy
william a mitchell invented all of them
all your favorite trashy food
the title
they call it trashy food in the title of
the article
thank you so i sometimes it is a burden
being this right
it is a burden when you can pull up
reports
listen we're way off base here we're way
off time well william a mitchell shout
out because she invented tang cool whip
and pop rocks
i find tang disgusting i can't taste it
uh
take it or leave it sunny d also i find
yeah it's it's orange beverage
disgusting yeah yeah now now let's get
back to
the pies okay you're telling me
here's something no human being has ever
said
especially in the united states of
america
man do you have peach pie nobody's ever
said that nobody's
ever been a diner and went yeah i love
you but if this podcast is gonna work
you have to make arguments that make
sense that makes sense you can't make a
statement joe
you can't i'm doing this and now i'm
actually being your bud in this
situation
you can't make a statement like no one
in the history of the united states has
ever said
do you have peach pods that's crazy i've
never seen it served after a holiday
meal
i've never seen it in a diner okay and
i've seen it
i mean i mean i i can't wait till we
disconnect and i tell you the last time
we ate it
actually because because lester who ate
it you we both but i i can't i can't
talk about it right now yeah
yeah cause it's it's a sensitive matter
but it's okay i'll i'll remind you later
i'll remind you later on i you've never
seen it served
i guess i got news for you oh i got news
i got new soya
if if i was anywhere and it was served i
said what are you nuts
[Laughter]
get it out of here i gotta be honest if
if an apple pie is on a menu and there's
also something like a key lime
or a like a boston cream or something
like that i'll always go
something other than apple apple is like
if you just have apple i'll have apple
but i'm taking a key lime even a i know
i even
even sometimes a lemon meringue i'll
take a lemon meringue sometimes over an
apple depends on what i'm in the mood
for but if you're talking about throwing
down the gum you don't like peach pie
you don't like peach pie i like it
i mean every word about to come in my
mouth i mean it
it takes every element i love about
peaches
and ruins it it doesn't taste like
peaches anymore to me
what it tastes like pushy pie sweet
flavorless kind of fruit apple pie you
haven't had good peach pie buddy
apple pie is more reminiscent of a peach
to me because of the tartness
peach pie is never every time i've had
it or peach cobbler it never has the
tartness of a peach
okay it never has the juiciness it's all
gone it's all just
hot slop and i hate it
i mean that is not hot slop and if
anything
all pi becomes hot slop you can't assign
hot slop to peach pie
and not say that apple pie is not hot
slob same thing happens with blueberry
pie
like like you lose all the crunch you
lose a crunch
of an apple in an apple pie i'm not i'm
not i'm not there for crunch
i'm not sitting there but it's hot slop
i just said what is all the brown
gel that brown gel like substance if you
look at the
at the apples and these pictures
especially that one on the left with the
the
i know it's a crumb one but when the
apple is prepared like that
that is a firm bite of pie you know why
i hate that
so the apples are sliced thin and long
ways yeah
if we're they slice those along see now
the one over there is the chunk
i prefer here's what i don't like about
the way that you just as the sliced ones
when you take the fork and you go down
it shoots out from the fork
fine and then you're not getting a
proper bite but do you know why it
shoots out because it's not mush
i've never had peach pie where i got a
firm bite of peach
in my life you're not eating the listen
i'm not here to debate
you know why i'm surprised you've eaten
you know why i'm not eating the right
peach pie
because nobody has the [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's my point
nobody has it i've never seen it on a
menu in my life
that's joe in my show joe joseph
you're crazy there was a diner and you
know what you know what though
do you want like peach pie is again it
has to be in season
and it also is like yeah it's it's not
there all the time it makes you want it
it makes you miss it
apple apple apple apple pie everything
the most standard things in apple pie if
i saw many that had an apple pie i would
be like you know what this place
can stand to be more creative with their
desserts i'll call a nice audible here
i'll call nice audible you could take
apple out of the mix
i still stand by it it's what i said i
was throwing down with okay
yeah cherry cherry crushes peach pie
i love a cherry pie okay well then we
agree on that we agreed a question i
actually i absolutely love chocolate you
agree that it crushes the peach
because that might well hold on you
think cherry you don't think cherry
crushes apple apples your number one
because i could have went up against you
with three pies because my favorite
three pies
are peach blueberry and cherry blueberry
i would
i wouldn't walk on it i wouldn't step on
a blue i'll tell you right now i even
only went peach now because i've been in
a real peach pie mood
but if you would have caught me at
another day cherry oh i'm telling you
blueberry might even
blueberry might even be my favorite pie
cherry's a grand slam
blueberry is the other pie i refuse to
eat
i'm dead serious i want the same reason
well look there's none of the wonderful
tartness of blueberry to it
it just tastes sugary the right
pies yes no i don't like that
i don't like that one no i don't like
that look at that that one i like
not that not that that no
no that's nice that's even i love the i
love when they do the weave too the
basket weave you know what blueberry pie
looks like
it looks like when you go to a fancy
restaurant the [ __ ] they drip around the
actual
food do you know what i mean when they
when they drip like red yeah like
conduction around the food
that's what blueberry pie inside look at
those beautiful blueberries are you nuts
again apple is it looks great it's a
beautiful looking you buy you know what
you do you know how you get apples this
there's so many apples we could stand
chop down half the apple trees and we
still be fine
you go you go with your friend apple
picking it's like 99 cents for the
family
take as many as you can hold that's how
you do apple picking they're like please
take the [ __ ] apples from the farm
come on in we're doing deals it's the
whole family everyone
they buck they give you baskets and
buckets they say take as
many as you can bring home it's not a
special fruit
a blueberry is a special fruit a
beautiful cherry it's a special fruit
we're not arguing the value of a
blueberry or a peach
a peach cherry we're arguing with the
value of the pie version
off with the apple enough it's a better
pie
blueberry pie is not good do you put a
pizza apple is not a better pie put
american cheese on it like a real
garbage plate do you do that put on what
blueberry pie
people do that you know american cheese
you never heard of this no
people put a melted slice of american
cheese they don't no they don't
i i literally almost wear my own mouth
sal i swear on my
life people melt american cheese on
blueberry pie
they 100 do that right there
pie with cheese ancient tradition or an
alamo but that's not blueberry that's
apple
[Laughter]
no that's peach i think we could find
out by clicking
oh it is apple it is apple people melt
cheese on pie it's disgusting that is
gross it's disgusting i guess it's sweet
savory is that the deal
it's disgusting my my friend did it with
blueberry pie that's one of the reasons
i always hated
i mean it keeps coming up with apple
buddy that's that's i mean that's a
craft single dropped right on top of
your favorite
it's disgracing your pie it's hard i
mean i and by the way
we're googling we're googling blueberry
pie
american cheese and only apple pies are
coming up listen just because
some [ __ ] animal put this blog up
about american cheese on pie i guess you
have cheese with fig and cheese with
grape
you know like on a platter so i guess
like a cheese danish with fruit is
tremendous
yeah that's true but but not like that
dude
that's a it's a different cheesecake is
great you might have to dabble in a
little uh
marijuana and see if that works brother
i've had it it's disgusting
really it doesn't taste right because
he's a garbage person
he's a garbage person he's going to
prove it through and through that's what
he is
i i i mean i i'm just letting you know a
peach is a special fruit i mean apple
like it's apple juice it's apple cider
it's
apple applesauce we've discussed that
apple juice is the best juice
we've discussed it oh my god please stop
what
i love we've discussed it nothing's
happening i love martinelli's they take
nothing away from the apple juice but
you just called it the best juice
what do you think tops apple juice i
mean a fresh-squeezed orange juice my
friend
apple juice could take a while apple
juice causes children's teeth to rot and
fall out and they look weird
you're talking about hacky and you're
saying orange juice
there's a reason it's the best juice
there's a reason there's a reason this
is the reason apple
pie is the best just please mark it down
please mark it down
let's go let's come back to it all right
because you're bat [ __ ] i'm not even i
love apple juice
i love it but i couldn't have it every
day aren't you
crazy yeah you know what i want to have
with my breakfast now we're now doing
we're now doing another episode we have
to go back
all right wait hold on just hold your
hold your tongue i was like worried like
i was like are we gonna find like more
of us that's like coming out as we're
doing these
i got i got a lot to say okay juice okay
no but shoot no not now
no i'm not gonna say okay okay i'm
saying hold your tongue where are we on
time mike
okay all right let's let's go to the
polls so we don't go over again
and let's see where it's at because i
want to have the time to read some
comments i will say
i believe i believe that you're going to
win this one because apple pie
is americana and it's the most
traditional and it's and it is
it is out there
that's not that's not right that's one
vote one vote
but they did what the other guy did with
the uh that he did the same thing that
everything bagel guy did unless yeah
okay here we go babe
this one's gonna be hard to shake this
one's gonna be hard to shake
this is like bombing in front of your
parents
are you so you're about to eat humble
pie oh my god am i eating this
but i knew i knew it's fine but i would
have seen i mean
that's like saying yankees versus like
you know don't you backpedal now take
your medicine what was the number
six thousand approximately six thousand
votes here so far
you got apple 86 14.
holy [ __ ] 86-14
buy a landslide i mean i know he's gonna
win i think he'll win by that much
holy [ __ ] but you're in america dude go
to europe and ask
go go somewhere else and ask do you hear
me make these excuses
glo globally go hear these excuses but
yeah you're right when i was in italy
they couldn't stop talking about the
peach pies
yeah no but but but but a map but a
baseball is america's past time and so
is apple pie is
associated with americana so i had no i
knew i was never winning there
i didn't think it would be 86 14. apple
pie apple tart
the only place i've ever seen peach
cobbler is in a vegas buffet
it's not a good food you're insane
i'm not insane just because you choose
to eat [ __ ] pie
like [ __ ] peach pies don't need it
he goes peach pies are disgusting i had
one
at a vegas buffet you keep making my
point for me i just go to your local
go to your local person who's dying who
go to a dynamite pie place i'm gonna go
to a pie man
do you want a pie man i do there's
people there's so many good pie places
in this okay listen to me
i'm saying i'm not saying i've only
eaten it from baker face i'm saying the
only place i ever even
come across it is it is at a buffet in
vegas well you
i don't know what you're doing with your
life but go into a nice bakery in new
york city the place where you live
and don't pay don't pay 7.99 on fremont
street and complain to me
about about the quality of peach you're
getting okay i do wonder i do wonder
if i would have went cherry or blueberry
because i could have gone
i do wonder if they would have fared any
bet i bet you had cherry pie
i bet your cherry pie would have fared
better i might want to revisit
i want my apple rematch and i take a
different pie
i can't argue against cherry apples my
number one
but cherry is so valid you there has to
be
the episode should have been cherry i i
i should have picked cherry the point is
no no no i'm gonna not be able to sleep
tonight now because this was a this is a
waste
you need contenders i'm saying we
wouldn't have had an episode if you
picked cherry
part of oh would have been closer it
might have been 60 40. might have been i
might have won
my point is is i don't dislike cherry in
any way i love
cherry pie i understand but i can't
disparage it in any way
whereas whereas i got to be in the mood
for an apple i also disparaged apple
yeah you had you you had it you had a
thing about apple you didn't like it's
like
i'll eat an oreo and i'll [ __ ] all over
it but you know before i eat it though
yeah you said you wouldn't cross the
street but
i'm not always i'm not always going to
not cross the street for one
you know what i'm saying yeah like
there's some cherry pie you like
you just like apple more so it wouldn't
have been a little contender i love
cherry pie i love apple pie apple pie to
me is the all-time great
a shot because if i would cherry chose
cherry we wouldn't hadn't we wouldn't
there would have been no debate we're
sitting here going two delicious pies
and you would have said the mean [ __ ]
you said about apple pie and i would
have said i can't
insult cherry pie i love it now if you
pick blueberry
i would add even more to say that i said
about peach
because that's a you know i don't
read some comments i can't even let's
read some comments
whoever says peach should be arrested
[Laughter]
okay well i'm just gonna write back welp
all right we got uh
okay the clear winner is apple but i
can't stand a cooked apple so it's peach
for me
uh i love apple pie but only cold i need
peach first apple comments people when
we start looking at the podcast and you
ever see
the twitter poll come out please don't
deviate and apply
your reasoning to this just we want to
hear your comments but you want to hear
them
about these singular two things that are
going head-to-head please
please all the buddies out there the
taste buddies please
that's good we all right we just named
the audience yeah uh look at this this
comment that right here
i went with peach that being said i've
never had peach pie
that's how much she detests apples
i mean but my sight unseen blind what
the hell is peach pie
it's not a product that you find
anywhere it's my point
it is two though it is two peach pie
is a pie okay apple pie for sure but
peach cobbler beats apple pie any day
i told you about the complex yeah i told
you about it
apple but only because there was no
pecan okay i don't need that
apple pie but peach cobbler there you go
so apple pie hands down no question
i chose peach but typically peach comes
in a cobbler form not a pie
this is where i might have went wrong
buddy i might just i should have put up
peach cobbler against apple pie no yeah
yeah yeah we did
yeah i could have done that cobbler's
not pie because there's apple cobbler
too
and i don't i'm not a big apple cobbler
guy either
some guy wrote once again this isn't
even close but whoever said pete should
go to jail
uh yeah i do yeah no
this guy look at this um you must go to
matatuck long island and try the peach
or any p cream pie at this farm stand
you will remember it
bremer bree or mere
rear mirror farms the winner the winner
response is this year
should we pick a winning response every
week we should should we do that we
should and just call him out we'll just
give him a shout out
yeah so people have it like you know
that's the winner right and you got to
play by the goddamn rules though
that's the winner right there she put
the gif up from american pie when he
sticks his finger in the apple pie and
he sticks it in that's that's the winner
okay so that's that's
we just got a new new thing at the end
we are going to crown the best comment
uh on this and we will we will call out
your twitter handle
and and call you out i will say little
rules it should be strictly
about the comment a comment on one of
the two things we did not like what you
think that you would do with another pie
uh
you know it doesn't help to be it
doesn't help if it's funny it doesn't
not help if it's
what am i trying to say i think i'm
having a stroke i know what you're
saying i know what you're saying
do you agree that that's the winner or
no uh
what the hell the hell is a peach pie uh
what the hell is a peach pie it's a
great one too
that that might be my favorite actually
i'm sorry to get the other person
real sal really peach be better peach
smh shaking my head look apple is
overrated says this person
cancel the poll all correct answers are
in
and they did the one hundred percent
yeah i'm not i mean i'm i'm having a
hard time finding people to back me with
the peach yeah
it is getting [ __ ] kicked out yeah i'm
having a hard time
wow man it is getting wow this person
says
definitely 90 of these people haven't
tried my grandma's peach pie
and there's a peach pie emoji thank you
uh i
i mean but again it's this like it's
this like completely
tiny narrow window like you've never had
the peach pie the one person i know that
makes it makes it's like yeah no [ __ ]
you know what i mean it's like nobody's
going oh the peach pie at denny's is
great
nobody's saying it again where you get
your pie is
just going you are going you love cool
whip and you like going to vegas buffets
and denny's
and then you take a [ __ ] on trader joe's
everything bagel seasoning
i'm just going broad and just making a
comment mcdonald's most popular
restaurant chain in the entire country
you'll find an apple pie in mcdonald's
you'll never see a peach pie
house of pies was the name of a
restaurant when i lived in la
that i used to go to every saturday
morning they never had peach pie
you're crazy you understand what i'm
saying so it shouldn't be cherry pie or
peach cobbler
i mean i really just i'm not gonna be
able to let i'm not gonna be able to
sleep tonight
every anything other than apple is just
un-american that latches on to me
they're voting for america here not the
pie
uh answers are paid for big apple has
their hand in this poll
big apple has their hand in this poll
let's crown the winner i think what
i think the hell is peach pie is the
winner the hell is media
uh and that comes to us from handel at
real unlyric lyrical
r-e-a-l-u-n-l-y-r-i-c-a-l
at real on you will also get a favorite
there you go
we named it and i hearted ya there you
go that's fun i like that
i won't because we want to hear it we
want to hear your snide comments too
much you give a retweet
yeah okay just do it now i'm not doing
that okay all right fine that's fine i
i don't know i don't know we're liking
and taking the handle
yeah it's good all right that's our show
folks
oh hold on a second
okay this is oh wow even now neil
brennan's getting okay this this
the people people are in so that's it do
you still i still love you buddy i love
you too
thanks for listening taste buddies uh
plugs
without a country the podcast where
corinne fisher and i
discuss the news every week uh gas
digital network every tuesday comes the
live stream
every saturday it hits wherever you get
your podcasts all over the place
uh you can get a free 30-day trial
overcast co
promo code wac and uh pat
walsh and i have a podcast called we'll
see you in hell where we review movies
of all genres
that catalog at uh starburns media and
wherever your
podcasts new episodes only at
patreon.com
wsyihpodcast
the whole time i'm drinking a cherry
pomegranate salsa that's nice it's there
all along that's nice it's in front of
me all along
uh check out my podcast with chris the
stefano called hey babe
also on this channel uh check out uh
jokers coming out soon again and misery
index season three
we're filming that now and then dinner
party is starting up very soon or it did
start up already depending on when this
is released
have fun and uh bring these debates to
your friends and uh
subscribe to the youtube right subscribe
to the youtube channel
and yeah all the other stuff too taste
buds
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste
and taste birds